senator bernie sanders who lost his last
bid for president is now leading the
polls in the packed field of 2020
democratic candidates today four of his
opponents in that race are co-sponsoring
his universal health care plan in the
senate it is called medicare for all
that'll keep spoke with a self-declared
Democratic Socialist in an interview
you'll see only on CBS this morning good
morning good morning Nora these days
you're more likely to see senator
Sanders out on the campaign trail than
here in the halls of Congress but he's
back today to introduce an updated
version of one of his signature
proposals long considered too radical by
many Democrats it's now central to how
the party talks about health care we
have a chance for Medicare for all
it's a common refrain of the Democratic
presidential campaign I believe in
Medicare for all that is why I'm
supporting Medicare for all I support
Medicare for all but what is Medicare
for all it guarantees like every other
major country on earth health care to
every man woman and child in this
country is this proposal socialism no
actually it is not similar to what the
Canadians have under the Sanders plan
all Americans would be covered by a
government backed program like Medicare
all necessary health care would be
covered but at a cost
some put the price tag at 25 to 32
trillion dollars over the next decade
this sounds expensive what's expensive
and what's unsustainable is the current
health care system and what if I have a
private or employer-based insurance
program right now and I like it well you
may be one of the millions of people who
leaves your job this year you're gonna
leave your private insurance you may be
one of the many millions of people who
finds that their employer has gone out
and got another insurance company to
cover you even have to change that but
essentially under Medicare for all all
people will be covered by Medicare and
what happens to those insurance
companies after your plan is implemented
under Medicare for we cover all basic
health care needs so they're not going
to be there to do that I suppose if you
want to make yourself look a little bit
more beautiful you want to work on that
nose areas they can do that so basically
Blue Cross Blue Shield would be reduced
to nose jobs something like that
the Senators bold proposal doesn't
account for the thousands of people who
work for those insurance companies and
what would happen to them under his plan
we reached out to Blue Cross Blue Shield
for comment but didn't hear back Anthony
yeah thanks I think everybody wants to
see a better health care system some
questions how do we get there